how'd you get banned from the cosmo
oh
so I'm may or may not have had a firearm
uh yeah would you say you may not have
had one may not have had one um you
can't have one there
you got to tell them before you come in
oh I mean you know there was that
shooting in Vegas I didn't know that
though I'm I'm [ __ ] 22 bro you know
there was like a guy in a room shooting
people like yeah like [ __ ] I ain't no I
didn't know none of that so they found
out you had a gun when they found out
and they seen it allegedly allegedly and
they seen it it was like and then when
they told me what happened I'm like uh
okay like I get that like yeah I get
that I'll get why y'all babe but I'm I'm
licensed though this is uh is this is
this the night you ran into ddg in Vegas
yeah it is it's that same night yeah it
is are you guys okay now
nah bro he was just here yesterday he's
such a nice guy and you're such a nice
guy bro
I'm Gonna Keep it honey I don't wow I
was gonna say I don't know why he got a
problem with me but yeah I mean I know
why but why is it did you [ __ ] Ruby Rose
no I didn't like I don't know I always
assumed you smashed Ruby Rose or
something man man Ruby man Ruby was cool
if you ever make out with her nah
nothing I want a lot of you subscribe to
her only fans no no no what the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] let's go to Reddit it's free
yeah
what is Reddit I don't know I have no
idea I have no idea you know because why
do you know that
I have no idea all right so here's the
thing right with him though
I don't I don't know I I never really
because supposedly where you guys ran
into each other was Vegas right yeah
yeah but well it's that [ __ ] like you
know I don't got no problem that really
had I don't have no reason to really
have a problem I feel like if you guys
hung out together you guys would get
along because he's a really nice guy
you're a really nice guy he's a very
smart guy you're a very smart guy you're
two different people though kind of
quite I mean look I mean but maybe
you're not you don't know I mean I would
I wouldn't even say that I wouldn't no I
ain't even gonna say we two different
people because we don't been around each
other but like I don't know bro I really
don't man is it all about a girl though
is that what the kind of because I feel
like most issues I really don't I don't
care they had no friends in this [ __ ]
but I ain't got no problem why so if any
so if any if any like well artists
really don't like me all that [ __ ] be
over a girl like and that [ __ ] ain't
nothing